open
all right everybody we are going to open
this up and let people start coming in
we'll give everyone a few minutes just
to come in
brian lewis is here brian good to see
you it's been a long time
let's see what's up michael sampson
you're here
a lot of people flowing right now i'm
going to miss everybody i'm not sure
who's coming in anymore
but it's good to see everybody i think
paul puglia's here
antonio cruz
yeah let's give everyone a few moments
of flowing i've noticed with these zoom
things
a bunch of people all coming at once at
all it doesn't all happen once it flows
in
makes it look like it's people flowing
into a room in real life
oh gavin kevin simpson good to see you
he got one of our previous speakers from
just a few months ago
okay so as people roll in we'll just uh
sit here and say hi to who can i build
gold one of our speakers katarina
another speaker
a lot of a lot of speakers speaking
coming up for this talk
okay for those of you just coming
there's some exciting announcements out
of our studio today you know max put out
his new
used model package and they also put up
the torch package today those are all
fun i had a fun day reading those blog
posts
okay
all right as people start to come in
we'll start rolling slowly we'll do our
normal
announcements so first thing everyone
welcome to the september meetup we uh
squeeze it in with
one day left to go in the month uh we
are very excited for this uh before we
even get started
as you always do jobs now obviously we
can't all be announcing jobs
in the slack right now so people
including automated channel
here uh you called the channel
the um september so thank you mother
september 29th meetup so everyone
go into there but if you have a job
posting actually we love getting people
jobs
go to the job postings channel uh value
model can you
can you make a link directly to a
channel and and send it on
and zoom if you can that'd be awesome um
anyone's looking to hire people go to
the job postings channel
and post your job in there if you're
looking to get a job go
into the job postings channel and apply
to them nice uh
bringing people together hopefully one
day we'll be able to do this again in
person when i can actually have
people go up to each other in the room
say hey i'm hiring hey i'm looking for a
job we love this
uh so again if you have a job you're
looking to hire someone go to job
postings post it right in there
i hope we'll get some people some work
um in one second
pizza i know we all are missing our
communal pizza
this month i got my pizza from a place
called brothers it's been sitting here
for a little bit so it's very good
cheese lock
see on the back this was it has some
charring which would make me think it
was made in a coal oven but i know this
place uses a gas oven
so i'm not sure what's going with that
that at the bottom there but you tell by
the
the coloring that it was indeed gas so
we're not gonna be disappointed by that
so everyone has their pizza from
wherever they're enjoying it from
i hope you got it from somewhere good or
at least somewhere you like uh and
hopefully everyone's having a
you know good quarantine of your pizza
i've been going to so many different
pizza places it's kind of nice
followed by a lot of ice cream so let me
just put that pizza off to the side
i'd like to thank eco health alliance
for providing the zoom link again thank
you very much uh
gnome for providing this for us every
month it's been
really really helpful getting this link
from you oh hold on i have a visitor you
want to come here
sorry buddy i have someone zoom bombing
uh so he's just gonna have to join us
for a little bit
uh he has an r t-shirt which he's not
wearing right now has a few r t-shirts
so thank you ecohealth alliance it's
been a very helpful them enabling us to
do the zoom meetings
it's been really great uh coming up
we're announcing
in this week are you done with me okay
we are we are announcing
uh this week our annual
our conference in washington dc uh it
takes place early december oh there's
becky say hi becky
hi a regular member of the meetup um
she hasn't been coming off so i was off
tonight marks of the baby but hopefully
she could attend for this one
so in december december 3rd and 4th we
have our third annual
our conference in washington dc uh this
year we're really focusing on
government ngo local nonprofits defense
and all sorts of things revolving around
the federal sector and local governments
and state governments
we have a great lineup coming at you
that will be officially announced soon
but it's really packed this year with
people working for the fda
for i believe the cdc for the defense
department for
the international development bank maybe
the world bank bunch of different
organizations
we're really really excited for this um
well again we'll be announcing this
either this week or next week officially
uh we'll be sending out an email blast
and the sign up page but you can go to
rstats.ai to check out what's up there
for now
and speaking of rstats.ai you can go
there and check out
soon not quite yet but very soon we'll
have all the videos from this year's nyr
talk nyr conference that includes
all of the great speakers like max [ __ ]
david robinson
emily robinson luda we have just a whole
fun day andrew gelman's videos it's
going to be a lot it's a whole
great trouba videos coming up
sorry folks you hear a little screaming
um we have
our next three months planned out for
the meetup i know that rarely happens
we're really super excited that we
actually have three months planned in
advance
we even have the dates for most of these
in advance which i don't have on me but
we'll look at that
next month we have katarina
constantinescu
talking about data validation it's going
to be fun
then in november we have henrik bengston
talking about the future package and
doing parallel computing
very easily using the various future
packages there's so many of them
and then in december we'll have will
landau talking about targets
if you remember a few months ago we had
a talk about
drake um that came from miles mcbain
well targets is the next iteration of
drake so it's gonna be interesting to
see how they stack up to each other how
they compare
and by the way these last two speakers
um henrik and will
the way we got them i noticed they were
attending the talk about drake
and they mentioned the comments i said
to them hey you folks want to give a
talk we have november december open
and they're speaking november december
it happens that way so
whoever wants to be the january speaker
send us a message you know how to get in
touch with me um
you know you can find me at
jaredlander.com send us some messages on
slack
send us a send a moda message send
anyone
any of my team members a message and
we'll see who wants to give a talk
that's what happens we have our speaker
this month who i you've watched his
videos online and i sent him an email
hey you want to give a talk and
he said yes that's how it happens here
folks so that's all of my announcements
amada did i miss anything
i'm not right now right we have three
awesome meetups and the
our conference yes focusing on
government that's it
great oh and stand workshop we've done
usually we do one stand workshop a year
this year we might do a second stand
workshop because it's all virtual so
maybe
coming up later this year we'll do a
stand workshop we'll see about that
so with all that stuff coming to us all
the way from long island
not quite as far as other people but
still far away in these times
we have a speaker who like i said i've
been watching his videos on youtube for
quite a while now i've learned a lot
about customizing my command prompt and
like i'm guessing many of you
you started using r the command prompt
is a little scary for you like r felt
comfortable you could do what you're
doing
but the command prompt sends a little
far and what if i screw something up
and even though you might be good at
coding that was always off-putting at
least for me and i'm assuming that a lot
of people feel that way so i've been
watching uh
nick's videos for a while now it's made
me feel a lot more comfortable made me
have a much better command line
experience
so i'm very excited to bring to us all
the way from the middle of long island
nick
please join us thank you very much for
speaking nick yeah no problem
thanks a lot for having me and uh hey
everyone thanks a lot for coming
my name is nick gennaticus and today
we're going to go over creating a
command line driven
development environment by the end of
this talk you'll be well on your way to
having a tricked out terminal
along with being familiar with tools
like tmux and vim
and also being comfy using command line
tools to solve real world problems
we're also going to go over how you can
manage your dot files these are files
that typically live in your home
directory
and they're responsible for configuring
a bunch of command line tools
just a heads up everything we go over
today is going to work on all major
distros of linux mac os
and windows 10. in the case of windows
it will be expected that you're using
wsl1
or wsl2 which is the windows subsystem
for linux
that's because we're going to focus on
shell scripting in a unix or unix-like
environment
not so much powershell also we're going
to cover a lot of ground in this talk
but
don't worry i'm not going to leave you
hanging on installing and configuring
everything on your own from scratch
feel free to check out this git repo
afterwards it has a very skimmable
reference for everything we're going to
cover
as well as the slide deck with that said
let me uh quickly introduce myself
my name is nick genitakis and i've been
a freelance web developer
for the last 20 years years and i would
say for the last seven or so years
i've been doing a lot of devops work
that's mainly setting up linux servers
working with various cloud hosting
providers deploying code
writing shell scripts and using tools
like docker ansible and terraform
now the specifics aren't too important
but i do think working with a bunch of
different technologies and projects
has led me to having a command line
focused development environment
now chances are you're not using the
same tech stack as me
but we can only use the same commands to
solve our unique problems
for example i found myself bouncing
around so many different freelance and
open source projects
and i wanted a way to quickly switch
between them to get right back into a
project as if i never left
that led me to discovering tmux and
eventually vim
and by the way if you decide you don't
want to use vim as a primary code editor
that's completely fine
i only started using vim about a year
and a half ago mainly because the
combination of using the wood team box
really let me quickly switch between
projects on the command line
but even if you don't use vim there is
so much more to the command line than
code editing and tmux is really useful
in any case now before we dive into the
basics of using tmox and other tools
let me quickly go over a couple of
practical examples of how i use team ups
them in various command line tools in my
day-to-day
i'm going to kind of blaze through this
without explaining things in detail so
you can get a high-level overview of how
everything fits together
and see what types of workflows you can
create this way you can start thinking
about how all of this applies back to
your dev environment
then after that we'll go back and cover
how everything works and how everything
can be configured in more detail
also just a heads up for the sake of
time and avoiding silly mistakes like
typos
i decided to go with animated gifs for
demoing a few things
that means you'll occasionally see
animations that are looping indefinitely
and they may not line up exactly with
what i'm saying but i think you'll get
the gist of it lastly feel free to ask
questions if anything isn't clear
because i am prepared to jump into a
live terminal if needed
okay let's do this so here's a brand new
terminal that i just opened
and let's say i want to start working on
the source code to my flask course which
is a web application running in docker
i was working on that last night but
today is a new day
instead of opening everything from
scratch i can attach to a tmx session
that's running in the background
it already has vim open with the last
file i was editing along with the entire
app running inside of docker it's like i
never left i can immediately get back
into the thick of it
next up let's say i want to do a
project-wide search for all the tests in
the project
i can do a search for the test
underscore string and then we'll do
a fuzzy search and list all the matches
also instead of a string
i could have used a regular expression
after that vim will present me a way to
filter and select matches i want
and even shows a little preview of the
file as i cycle through the matches
my font size is massive here for the
sake of the talk but normally you can
see a lot more of the file in the
preview
then from here i can pick a file and it
opens in the main buffer
if i want to look at multiple files at
once then makes it easy to open
horizontal and vertical splits
it looks a little cramped here because
of that font size with my normal setup i
can actually fit four
80 character with file side by side on a
2560x1440 monitor
running at need of resolution also i
didn't show it here but it's really easy
to switch between different splits
using hotkeys with the mouse
that's about one of many awkward drinks
for today
now let's say that you want to open a
different set of files but
you don't want to lose your existing
layout of files with vim you can open
files in a new tab
and this tab becomes a bucket to hold as
many files as you want
then you can switch between tabs up top
using the hotkeys and the mouse
so let's say we did some work and now
it's time to commit our changes
i can hop over to the second tmux window
on the bottom open a split
and make my get commit message as an
aside tmux also supports horizontal
and vertical splits i also like using
vim here for writing commit messages
because it helps me adhere to best
practices
such as warning me through syntax
highlighting if the first line is too
long
or if i have any typos like we see here
next up let's say that you have a few
t-mic splits open
and you really want to view the live
details in full size but you don't want
to close your existing splits
tmux lets you zoom in and out of any
split you want i'm just hitting a hotkey
there to toggle the zoom in
and out also it's worth mentioning you
can do the same thing with vim splits
too
i didn't show it for the sake of time
also as a reminder we're going to see
how to do all of these things later on
when we dive into the details
now let's say i want to jump to a
completely different teamwork session
in this case it's my podcast site and
maybe i came here to add a reference
link
or something like that after doing
whatever i needed to do i can jump over
to the second tmx window on the bottom
and deploy the site with ansible
ansible's deploy command is kinda long
and i don't have to sit there and hit
the up arrow 100 times to find it
so i can reverse search my history using
the same tool that we saw on vim
to fuzzy search through the files in the
project that tool is called fcf by the
way
lastly here's a quick demo of doing
github style markdown previews in vim
technically with this gif here it's not
real time since it's not updated on
every character press
but you can turn that option on if you
want i i keep it off for uh performance
reasons
instead it updates every time i switch
vim modes or save the file
also on the right vin puts orange
exclamation points near the line count
that's to let me know that these lines
have changed based on the most recent uh
reason get commit it'll show new lines
and deleted lines too
with different markers as well honestly
we could spend the whole hour looking at
vim and tmux features but
there's so much more to the command line
than using vim so
let's switch gears and go over a few
practical examples of using the command
line tools
for example let's say i'm working on
something and it sparks an idea for a
blog post
i can just run a custom script i created
called drafts and start typing whatever
i want
after running that command it
automatically creates a date labeled
file in my personal website's drafts
folder
if i rerun the same command it opens the
file in vim so i can start fleshing out
the draft right now
that's typically what happens in
practice this might seem like such a
minor thing but it really helps remove
friction when starting to write new blog
posts
because a tool i use to build the blog
expects files to be in this dated format
not having to create this file manually
means it's one less thing to think about
as for this draft script it's a simple
script and don't worry if you can't read
the text
uh the real takeaway here is the command
line is there to help you solve whatever
unique problems you have
it's almost like a direct link to your
brain except you have to type what you
want instead of thinking
in another example i created a script to
toggle dark and light mode for my
terminal
tmox vin and other tools i prefer using
light mode in my day to day
but after running a poll i found most
folks like seeing a dark theme in my
video tutorials
so with this script i can very easily
change between the two
it's open source in my public dot files
and we'll take a look at that later
in one more example let's say i was
heading over to new york city later
tonight
but i wasn't sure if i needed an
umbrella because i live 90 minutes away
and weather is crazy like that
not a problem i can just run weather nyc
and see what it's like there
there's almost a tool for everything in
this case the weather command is a very
simple function i set up in curl
a very simple function i set up to curl
wttr.in
which is a website that shows you the
weather in a browser but it's also
optimized for displaying the weather on
the command line
there's also dozens of general purpose
unix tools that you can use to solve
problems around processing and filtering
text
i'm not sure if you saw it but man this
guy's name was really hard to pronounce
but it was something
like irene johnson's from this group he
gave a talk about exploring data on the
command line
a few years ago i highly recommend
checking it out it's a good primer on a
few command line tools
but that said i'm trying to keep this
talk focused on workflows and more
generally your dev environments but
besides using tmux and vim piping
together a few unix commands and writing
your own scripts to solve your specific
problems
is a huge part of using the command line
it becomes another tool at your disposal
with that said let's take a couple of
minutes to go over one example of doing
this
so imagine if you have a csv file with a
bunch of transactions in it
and you want to extract down information
like how much money you generated but
also have an ability to filter the
results by specific product names date
ranges and so on
the csv file we're looking at here is a
very simplified version of a csv
that my course platform spits out with a
bit of anonymized data
in practice you'll find payment gateways
like stripe and paypal supplying your
transaction information
in csv files so this is a real world use
case
as an aside vim has a plugin to help
view and display csv data
and we'll go over that a bit later but
viewing this data isn't super useful
typically i want to figure out things
like how many courses was sold this
month with an ability to filter the
results by course name and so on
and that begins with removing the csv
headers
sed stands for stream editor and in
practice it's a very useful tool for
doing a find and replacing text
but in this case we're using it to
delete the first line of the file
the 1d part stands for delete the first
line if we swap out the one with the two
then the first two lines would be
deleted instead one neat thing about the
command line is there's often more one
more than one way to do something
if you googled around for how to delete
the first line in a file you'll find all
sorts of different answers and most of
them will probably work
for example we could have used the tail
command and passed in these flags to get
the same exact result
technically tail is faster than said on
linux but apparently it's slower on mac
os by default
at least according to stack overflow
although i find the tail version to be
less readable
for this type of use case it's really
confusing because the plus one
actually outputs the entire file so we
need to offset what we want by one
and there's also very subtle differences
between using one and plus one
one takeaway here is you should probably
be mindful of performance
but readability almost always wins
especially if the performance difference
isn't anything worth considering for
example if we had thousands of rows and
the said version finished in five
milliseconds
but the tail version finished in three
milliseconds it doesn't really matter
for a script that i run once a month on
my dev box
but i will remember what 1d does instead
three months from now which has way more
value in the end
as an aside tail is still a great tool
if we wanted to get the last line or
last couple of lines of the file
then tail is for sure the way to go here
you can even have tail watch a file for
changes in real time
and i'll put new lines as they come in
that could be useful for monitoring web
application logs but moving on before
we're going to be using said version and
the next thing we'll want to do is
filter out a specific
column of text this column is the net
amount of sense and it's the thing we
want to sum up in the end
unix was invented a long time ago and
they made some really great design
decisions such as being able to pipe the
output of one program
as input into another and you'll also
find that text streams are the protocol
that most commands use that means most
command line tools expect text as input
and produce
text as output this is remarkably
powerful because suddenly it means you
can combine hundreds of tools
in a number of different ways to solve
very specific problems
that you might have and unix pipes are
the secret sauce that lets us send the
output of one program
as input to another pipes are defined
with this vertical line
and you can see it here sitting in
between set and cut that means in this
case
the output of the set command is now
being fed in as input to the cut
commands
and this cut command is going to delimit
the output by a comma since this is a
csv file and we want to grab the fifth
column
which is the net amount in sense if we
ever wanted to calculate the transaction
fees
for a specific payment gateway then we
could change this five to a four
and now it would get the previous column
which are those fees and this is why the
command line tools are amazing
we get to break down the problem into
bite size chunks and then work on only a
very specific tiny problem at hand
i think this fits the functional
programming model very nicely
speaking of which a lot of functional
programming languages also have the idea
of a pipe operator
where you can send the output of a
function as input to another function
it's a great way to break up a problem
next up let's say that
we have a list of amounts we'll want to
sum them up but before we can sum them
we need to transform the list of numbers
into a map equation that adds each value
for that there's the paste command don't
ask me why it's name paste because i
have no idea
it has nothing to do with your clipboard
all i know is when we use these flags it
becomes what we see here
if you wanted to do something else like
subtract the values you can replace the
plus at the end with a hyphen
technically you can use this paste tool
for anything it's not limited to math
if we put an underscore there instead it
would delimit them by that
by the way the dash d is the delimiter
and slash or dash
s puts everything onto one line and now
we have our equation ready to go and we
can use the
basic calculator command aka the bc
command to sum them all up
and there we go we solve that problem by
piping together a few commands
in practice when you're more familiar
with these commands you can create
pipelines like this in a few minutes
by the way there's gotcha here with the
bc command 2. if you ever want to
support floating point numbers
you'll need to add the l flag to it i
didn't add it here since we're dealing
with summing whole numbers
so there's never going to be a decimal
point next up let's filter the results
by a specific course
using the grep tool this tool you'll
likely find yourself using all the time
you can provide it a text stream or a
file and then we can match whatever
search string we want
in our case it's a regular expression
that makes for a comma bsawf is at the
very end of the file
that's just uh like an identifier for
build assassination flask the name of
one of my courses
this is nice because it means we no
longer need to use the set command
to chop out the first line since this
correct pattern will only ever match csv
rows that have this specific text
then from here we can use what we did
before to sum up the net sales
and suddenly we have the total sales for
a specific course
i also decided to throw in two more
examples here at the end
the first one lets us count the number
of sales for a specific month
here we just take the output of what
produces and pipe it into the word count
command the dash
l flag counts the number of lines
instead of words
alternatively grep has a c flag to get a
count of the results
instead of returning each match on a new
line in practice i would use the second
command if i wanted to count
it's less typing less overhead and more
straightforward to read
so that's a mini crash course and
combining a couple of commands together
to solve a real world problem the cool
thing is if you find yourself writing
scripts like this
then you know if they start to get a bit
unwieldy you can put them into a
dedicated script file and run them like
that we'll talk more about shell scripts
a bit later
yeah there's no reasonable way to drink
stuff on a zoom call
and now that leads us into the next part
of this talk we just covered a bunch of
practical workflows and examples of
using the command line
now it's time to get into the details
about setting up your dev environment
and that begins with picking a terminal
and configuring your shell
we're going to spend quite a bit of time
on this because it's pretty core to your
environment
the interesting thing about tmux is it
gives you tabs splits
and a way to search up and down a buffer
in any terminal
this allows us to pick a terminal that
focuses on speed
and having the least amount of input
latency when you press keys
you can also optimize for quality of
life enhancements too like having
customizable hotkeys
being able to zoom in and out being able
to click urls
and also have solid unicode support for
displaying icons and emojis
if you're going to be spending a lot of
time typing into something it should
feel really good
and make you happy while doing it for
example i'm using windows and the
microsoft terminal
has really low keypress latency it's
like night and day compared to most
other terminals on windows
i tried a whole bunch and the only other
terminal i found that was really good
was wsl tty but i've gone with the
microsoft terminal because it's more
integrated with being able to easily
switch between wsl distros
as for anyone running native linux xterm
is a very lightweight terminal
and has pretty much the lowest input
latency i've ever encountered on any os
also with a bit of configuration it has
all the marks on the quality of life
improvements
i do run native linux on a modified
chromebook and i'm always amazed at how
nice the
terminal experience is for mac os to be
honest i'm not 100
sure since i have no first hand
experience but i've heard that item 2 is
pretty solid so you may want to start
there
in addition to that there's
cross-platform terminals like alacrity
which is something you may want to check
out too but personally on windows and
linux i've always used the microsoft
terminal
and xterm and i think the takeaway here
is
it doesn't matter too much in which
terminal you pick because tmux brings a
lot to the table
so just stack up on speed and quality of
life improvements and they wouldn't
worry too much about native terminal
support
for things like tabs splits and
searching next up it's time to pick a
shell
and your shell provides a command line
interface to your operating system
it's both interactive and can be used as
a scripting language
right now i happen to be running dash
and you can check what shell you're
currently using
by running echo dollar sign zero there's
also dollar sign shell too
but this is technically the default
shell for your system or user
not your current shell to help clarify
that another shell is
sh which is the bourne shell and it was
released way back in 1979.
if you're curious it's accessor bash
stands for the born again shell
and that was released about 10 years
later in 1989
but just because i'm running bash here
doesn't mean i can't use the original
burn shell
you can run it by running sh notice the
prompt changed
and now dollar sign zero returns sh
instead of dash
but dollar sign shell still returns bash
because for my nic user in the system
that's the set is the default typically
on minor systems you wouldn't use sh as
your interactive shell in your day to
day
it's missing very nice to have features
like being able to tap complete commands
or use the arrow keys to move the cursor
around however when writing shell script
it's often a good idea
to target your scripts for the shell
since it's the most compatible across
systems
although there's not too much harm in
targeting bashu because it's available
on most linux systems
and mac os we'll talk about shell
scripting in a bit but for now let's
focus on
the shelves themselves
any questions so far in the chat if you
want to relay some
uh you are good to go there's a few
things about
you know combat bat who maintains bash
stuff like that but you're good to go
okay cool yeah as for who maintains bash
not really sure probably some
guy with a very long beard but uh
brian lewis saying it's chet raimi from
cleveland
okay here we go so besides sh and bash
there's also a newer shell such as z
shell which is labeled as
zsh just like bash extended the original
bourne shell
z shell extends bash personally i'm not
a huge fan of it but it's not because i
think it's bad
or i have anything against it i'm just
content with bash
and i don't really feel like i'm missing
out on anything at the moment by the way
it's worth pointing out if you're
running a modern version of mac os
and you followed along before with the
dollar sign zero command chances are you
saw z
shell as your shell that's because macos
made it the default shell in the
catalina release which i think was in
2019
but even so bash is still available to
be run on mac os
and there's also fish which is an even
more recent shell and it stands for
friendly
interactive shell unlike z shell fish is
not compatible with sh or bash because
the creators thought certain design
decisions from back in the day
were kind of poorly designed so they
went their own way honestly this shell
isn't for me
mainly due to that lack of compatibility
but it might be it might be okay for you
it has a lot of out of the box features
like auto suggestions but you can also
get that to work with other shells too
it just takes a bit more effort
with that said at least now you know
these options exist we only have so much
time here so we can't spend a ton of
time breaking down the pros and cons of
each shell
but overall your shell is there to make
it a pleasant experience to use your
system from the command line
if you're curious now you could google
for things like bash versus csh first
for fish
and you can make an informed decision
just be aware that this is an excellent
topic to get lost in yak shaving or bike
shedding
in other words you can spend a lot of
time here and wind up with uh
not too many games the real games come
from learning how to create tools
that help you solve your exact problems
and getting comfy with workflows that
let you do whatever you need to do
quickly
it's not a life or death decision
decision either you can always switch
your shell later on without too much
flush
so that's a basic rundown of shells
since i happen to use bash
let's go over how i have it configured
although in a lot of cases even if you
plan to use z
shell or fish most of what we're about
to cover still applies
most shells have a few config files in
your home directory with bash you'll
have at least the bashrc file
and maybe a bash profile too in my case
i decided to rename my bash profile to
profile
so it'll work with any shell although
technically this profile file has one
line in it that's specific to bash
so it's not entirely portable across all
shells with that said
let's take a look at this file just a
heads up before we get into this
i'm only going to be showing a few lines
at a time so it's easier to talk about
this entire file along with all of my
config files are in my dot files repo on
github
and we'll cover that near the end as for
this profile file it runs once when you
log into your system
so it's a very good spot to put things
that don't change very often
for example i'm modifying my path here
so that any executable scripts or
binaries that exist in my home
directories
dot local bin directory are available to
run without supplying the entire path
that's how i ran the draft script before
it exists in my local bin directory and
i can run it like any other command
that's already on my system path
this is also where i like to set the
system defaults for certain tools that i
use
the editor variable controls which text
editor to open for example if a tool
needs to open a text editor
it opens vim by default due to this
being set the editor variable is a
standard
so a bunch of tools know how to read
from it we saw that before whenever we
get commit message
get new to open vim due to the setting
you can also choose to set your own
variables here if you want
i really like this pattern because it
means your settings are stored in one
spot
if 10 different tools decided to open
your default text editor
it means you only need to change this
variable in one spot if you wanted to do
something else
next up there's a bunch of configuration
to use syntax highlighting in certain
tools
like less and man and the man command
opens a reference manual for many
different tools
for example if you run man grep it will
open the manual for grep
this is a really good way to learn about
a specific tool you can also see their
syntax highlighting
without those environment variables we
just saw this would all be one solid
color
which is a bit harder to read lastly
this line does the dollar zero trick
which we did before
to see what shell we're running and then
if we're running bash and we have a bash
oc file present
it sources that file sourcing it
basically means
writing the script and any shell related
changes will take effect in your current
shell
if you're running z shell or fish then
you'd want to modify this last line
next up let's take a look at the bashrc
file for the sake of time
i'm going to try to keep things brief
rather than go into the gory details of
everything
this file executes every time you start
a new terminal session
that means every time you open a new
terminal window or spawn a new tmax
window
this bashrc file is going to run top to
bottom
the first five settings control your
history basically you want to save
the last 50 000 lines of history ensure
each line has its own timestamp
avoid adding duplicate or empty lines
and also append to the history file
instead of rewriting a new file
on every entry your your history is
saved in
your home directory with bash it'll be
in the bash history file
mine is nearly empty now because prior
to this talk i backed up my real history
files so i didn't have to worry about
showing sensitive commands during this
talk
you know some of them contain
information about client work and i
didn't want to leak those out by
accidents
speaking of history you can also take a
look at your history by running the
history command
that's useful to find commands you've
run in the past and with saving 50 000
entries
chances are you'll be able to find
commands you've run months ago but
grepping through this output would be
kinda painful so bash provides the
control r keyboard shortcut
to reverse search your bash history
we'll go over that in more detail once
we encounter a different part of this
bash rc file
the next couple of settings are default
values of the dash rc file
it's not really worth spending any time
on them but i included them here anyways
although it is worth mentioning that on
a linux system
you can check out what the default rc
file is by cutting out
etsy skill that rc that comes in really
handy if you're tweaking your bash rc
file
and just want to double check the
default value also in the scale
directory there's a couple of other
default configs that you can take a look
at if you're curious
next up we have aliases and these are
really really useful
the basic idea here is if an alias file
exists then we load it in
there's two files here because my dot
files are public on github and i wanted
the option to have a local aliases file
that's ignored from version control
this local file contains aliases that
are only ever going to be useful to me
and are super specific to private files
on my file system you know things like
accessing client projects and
other stuff with that said let's take a
look at the regular aliases file which
by the way in bash would be named
bash underscore elios is by default i
decided to go with aliases to make it a
bit more portable across different
shells
it still works as aliases because it's
tied into the file being sourced from
the bashrc file
we just looked at technically we can
name this file anything we want
as long as that matches up with what we
just saw the first couple of aliases are
defined by default
it's mainly for enabling colors and
popular commands like ls
and grep but it also includes a very
popular one called ll
i use this one all the time till this
directories and files
my real aliases file has over 20
different functions and aliases
but we could legit spend the next two
hours going over it but instead i just
want to focus on the big picture here
in my aliases file you'll notice there's
both functions and aliases
and both allow you to access the
function or alias as if it were a script
on your system path
if you plan to pass in arguments like
you see here then you would use a
function
otherwise you can use an alias for
example with the weather command we can
pass in a city
zip code or nothing and it all works the
same the dollar sign one
ends up being the value you passed in if
it's empty then it's treated as an empty
string
but in this case we have an alias that
takes no arguments and we saw this
command being run during the demo
instead of it just running the script on
its own it also sources the bashrc file
because it ends up changing the color of
a specific tool that depends on dash
being reloaded
that's kind of a neat trick because the
alias and script both have the same name
in this case the alias takes precedence
over the script's path
the takeaway here is don't be afraid to
create aliases that help you in your
day-to-day
you should try to mold your dev
environment to fit your exact needs
i think there's really a whole mindset
or philosophy around that especially
when it comes to using linux
with the amount of configuration you can
do it really becomes an os that you can
customize for you
one day i'll switch to native linux and
the only reason i don't do that now is
because i had some audio trouble with
some of my hardware
i bet if i were running native linux for
the last 10 years i would probably have
like 5 million aliases
and custom strips to help me in my
day-to-day anyways
that is it for aliases the next part of
my bash rc file is related to the prompt
and we haven't really gone over that yet
so let's quickly do that before we see
how it's configured
my prompt doesn't look like the bridge
of the uss enterprise and this really
comes down to personal preference
i much prefer a minimal prompt that gets
out of my way and lets me focus on the
commands i'm running
and the output of those commands but i
do like to see some information in my
prompt for example as we saw earlier
if you're in a get repo it will show the
branch name which i find to be quite
handy
beyond that i also like to see the
current directory of where i am since
that's pretty important as well
also if i ssh into one of my production
servers i like to configure the prompt
there to be read
to remind myself that i probably
shouldn't copy paste commands from the
internet here
or start running a bunch of commands
without thinking i don't drink much but
if i did
seeing this red color would be a last
resort reminder to hopefully prevent
myself from deleting a production
database into drunken rage
but no promises one takeaway here is
all of these command line tools are
super configurable if you don't like my
basic prompt and you'd rather have a
more busy prompt with emojis rainbows
seeing your battery life or hard drive
space on every line that's totally cool
and you can do that i've linked to a few
resources and they get repo on projects
that help you customize your prompt
in different ways with that said let's
see how to configure your prompt
aka your ps1 which stands for primary
prompt string
the syntax looks like total insanity and
it kinda is
but there is a silver lining once you
have it set up you never have to worry
about it again
until you get bored and want to change
things around we can spend an hour here
easy but
here's a low-hanging fruit bash provides
a bunch of special characters such as
slash u and slash h these are special
variables that translate to specific
things
in the case of slash u that's your
username and slash
h is the host of the machine in my case
my username is nick
and i named my computer kit if you're
old enough to remember knight rider
you'll get that reference
there's also this slash w hidden amongst
the sea of backslashes
that's the current working directory
which is temp in this case
there's also a number of other special
variables too they're mostly maybe
related to the date i've dropped a link
to the dash manual in the references if
you're curious
now besides those special variables most
of the other characters in this ps1
are related to output in color
these are called anti-escape codes and
it's kind of where the insanity begins
it's not that it's a terrible system
it's just that it requires a lot of
escaping
and also resetting colors back to the
default color after you've picked a
color
that's why you see zero zero entries
that's the reset code
as for picking colors if you google
around for anc color chart
you'll find a bunch of examples i
usually go to wikipedia for it but that
page has too much to show in one slide
so i made a more readable chart here we
can see a list of valid colors
fg is foreground and bg is background if
you remember my username and host were
green
so that would be foreground color 32 and
if you go back to the previous slide
here you can see 32 set for the username
and host we can also see
that 34 is set for the working directory
which is blue
and if we jump back to the chart again
there we can see 34 is blue
now there is a variation of these colors
called bright mode as far as i know
there are more than one way to uh set
these colors
honestly a lot of this stuff is black
magic to me i just copy paste things and
tweak it until i'm happy
but as for bright mode notice how there
is a zero one before the 32 and 34.
to my knowledge that flips on bright
mode for the color being set
if you set that to 0 0 instead it would
be the regular version of the color
apparently an alternative way to set
that is to add 60 to the value so
32 becomes 92 and 34 becomes 94.
keep in mind not all terminals and
themes are created equal
so you may see different results
depending on what you use
but here's a modified chart to show how
bright colors could look using xterm
with the default theme also my prompt
only modifies the foreground color of
text but you can set the background
color too
i'm going to leave that one up to you if
you want to research it you'll be able
to find lots of examples if you google
around
as for the command separator it's pretty
standard to end your prompt with a
dollar sign
this will end up being the character
that separates your prompt with whatever
command you're running
some folks like to use unicode
characters or an emoji years ago i used
a lightning bolt but eventually grew
bored of it
but don't let me talk about using
something else i really do encourage you
to mold your prompt and dev environment
to whatever you like if you did want to
swap out the dollar sign it's just a
matter of replacing it here at the end
as for this prompt the last component is
getting the get branch wedged in near
the end
the basic idea is we execute a function
here and the output of that function
ends up in its place that function is
defined in the middle here
and all it does is grab the current
branch
then it uses said to replace some
characters that get usually outputs when
you run
the git branch command also if the
command fails we redirect all errors to
dev null
which means if we're not naked repo we
end up with no output which exactly is
what we want
honestly it's not too important to go
through this function in detail i'm
pretty sure i sniped that from stock
overflow like seven years ago
and it still works for you today uh
there's other more fancy
integrations that you can add too such
as outputting specific characters
depending on the state of stage files or
if a file is different than what has
been commit
but in practice i don't really find that
to be that useful
typically that information can be
obtained in your code editor or using
git commands when you're ready to commit
something
but the branch is very nice to see
because being on the wrong branch can
cause all sorts of confusion
and typically while you're launching vim
or another editor you're already
actively looking at your prompt so the
branch is nice to see there
okay that's the prompt any questions so
far
or i'll just keep going and you just
jump in if there are so the next bit
here
updates the terminals window title
depending on which directory you're in
this only works if your terminal
supports it but it's part of the default
rc file so it's not super important to
go over
and every time i drink i'm laughing to
myself because it just looks so dumb
okay so next up we have asdf which is a
tool that helps you manage programming
language versions in a consistent way
it's not super important to cover that
now since it mainly relates to
installing
specific programming languages although
the vm plugin for previewing markdown
files does require having node installed
and i do use asdf to install node and
we'll talk more about this later
next up there's fcf which is a command
line
fuzzy finder we saw this in action
during the demo when searching through a
project in vim
as well as the command history this tool
replaced
replaces the default behavior for
reverse searching history and makes it a
lot better
searching your history is a really
important part of using the command line
so let's spend a minute or two going
over how to do this and how fcf
improves the experience when you hit
ctrl r and bash without fcf
you'll get a menu that looks like this
the basic idea is you can start typing
the first few characters of any command
you want
and it'll start showing you matches
based on what you've run in the past
in this case i'm searching for the
characters bs if there's multiple
commands that start with these
characters
you can cycle through them by hitting
ctrl r as many times as you want
it's called the reverse search because
it returns the last command that matches
in other words it searches your history
in reverse this is one of the most
useful things ever it sure beats hitting
the up arrow 42 times in a row to find
some command you ran three days ago
i use this feature probably a hundred
times a day uh you can pick the command
you want to run
by hitting enter and it'll populate the
command for you so in the above case all
i did was hit ctrl r
search for the bs characters and then
hit enter all in all this takes about
two seconds and it's very practical
by the way you can also cancel your
reverse search by hitting ctrl c
if you don't want to pick anything now
when you use fcf
control r is still available to run
except now it looks like this
then as you start typing it narrows down
the results in real time
in this case only commands that contain
the c character are returned
it's also a fuzzy search meaning if i
instead searched for the l character it
would have found the second match since
clear has an l in it
it ranks them based on what it thinks is
the best match it's really good i would
say probably
i don't know 99 of the time it picks the
command in one after typing a few
characters
even if it's searching through hundreds
of files in the one percent case when it
fails it's really no biggie i just type
one or two more characters
and it always finds it after hitting
enter to pick the item
it'll inject the command into your
prompt and then you can choose to run it
you can also hit ctrl c to cancel it
just like we did with control r before
fcf can also do a lot more than search
your history too you can use it to
search your process list and more
to be honest it deserves its own
45-minute talk it's a really useful tool
but now that we know how to search our
history efficiently let's go back to the
dash rc file
we saw these lines a few minutes ago
this controls enabling
uh and configuring fcf the bottom line
enables fcf
and the two optional lines above it
configure it fcf supports both dark and
light
themes and you can also customize the
colors individually however you see fit
but the line above that is a bit more
interesting to talk about
it configures fcf with a tool called rip
grep instead of the grep tool when it
searches for matches
rip rep is a much faster version of grep
now in practice i use grep in the
command line
because it's fast enough but fuzzy
searching is pretty demanding
and i find rip grip speed boost speed
boost to be worth it
it narrows down search results pretty
much as fast as you can type even with
hundreds of files
this is really important because the vim
plugin for fcf will use ripcrep when
searching for files to open
or searching your project for a specific
text during the demo i ran the rg
command which uses rip grip under the
hood
and fed the results into fcf installing
rip grep is easy because every major
operating system
has a version of it in its package
manager but i recommend holding off and
installing it for now
because there's a couple of tools
covered in my bash rc file and we'll
want to install them
and it's going to be a lot easier to do
that in one place when we take a look at
our dot files
and finally there's a bit of
configuration related to wsl2 and wsl1
this is mainly to set up a next server
display so you can have your clipboard
shared between wsl
and regular windows as well as run
graphical apps i don't want to really
spend any time on this one
but if you're using wsl the references
link has a link to a video that goes
over this in more detail
so that's how i have bash configured i
know
it was a lot to take in but we've really
just condensed multiple months of
research in about 10 minutes or however
long that
section took now before we get into
using tmox i do want to cover one last
thing
that's important when writing your own
scripts when writing shell scripts you
might have seen something like what we
see here
this is called a shebang and it's the
first line of the file that starts at
pound exclamation point
followed by a path to some type of
binary such as sh
bash or any programming runtime that can
be called from the command line
you um you may have also seen the style
of a shebang which technically works on
most systems
but it's less portable it's considered
less portable because the dash binary
might not exist in slash bin on some
systems
whereas user bin env exists almost
everywhere
i tend to use this style everywhere
unless i made a mistake and use the less
portable version by accident
speaking of portability remember when we
talked about using sh instead of bash
for scripting
the bourne shell aka sh is posix
compliant
and this is a standard that was created
to ensure compatibility between
different operating systems
to write a positive compliant shell
script you would reference sh instead
of bash in practice i tried to do that
but sometimes you really need the extra
features provided by bash
in which case i would use bash without
giving it a second thought
honestly we could spend another hour
here going over to solve the differences
between the two
so let's just leave it at that you can
always google for the differences later
with that said i think one of the best
ways to learn something is to see
fully working examples so i've dropped a
couple of links into the references to a
number of scripts i've
been sourced over the years to help me
in my day-to-day i'm not saying it's the
best code ever written
but i might get your noodle cooking to
see what types of problems you can solve
on the command line
all of the code is mit license too so
that's shells and scripting in a
nutshell
on that note we covered a lot but don't
feel compelled to learn everything
upfront before you do anything you can
slowly introduce things on
a need to know basis what i mean by that
is like any programming language or
environment
you can still be very productive without
understanding the entire language and
ecosystem
in detail next up let's go over using
tmox
unlike the shell we'll spend the
majority of our time using tmux instead
of configuring it
but we will take a look at some config
settings too first up
what is tmux good question i'm glad you
asked
tmux is a terminal multiplexer and what
that means
is it lets you create and control
multiple terminals from a single screen
we saw that before in the demo when
creating windows and splits
it also lets you create sessions which
can which you can attach to and detach
from
which is amazing because it means if you
close your terminal everything will
still be running in the background
and you can connect to any session at
any time to resume where you left off
you'll find team action whatever package
manager your operating system uses
so it's going to be no problem to
install but like before let's not worry
about installing it
and we'll take a look at that later for
now let's just focus on using it
one core feature of tmux is its ability
to control most things with hotkeys
but don't worry you can still use the
mouse for most things like selecting
text
clicking between different windows or
split panes but
since tmx was so hotkey driven they
introduced the idea of a thing called
the prefix key
the basic idea is you'll hit this key
along with some other key afterwards to
perform a specific action
this helps name space all of your tmx
hotkeys so you don't end up overriding
hotkeys from other tools i tend to call
this a leader key because that's what
vim defines it as
so you may hear me use both terms
interchangeably
by default it's bound to control b which
is in my opinion a bit funky to hit so
i've remapped my prefix key to be the
back tick
that's usually under the escape key or
to the left of a one on a standard
keyboard
in practice you'll find that lots of
folks use this key it's pretty easy to
access
and you really type it in your day to
day and when you do need to insert a
back tick somewhere
you can just hit the key twice it's
really no problem throughout the rest of
the section i'll always reference
hotkeys with the word prefix
instead of using the backtick directly
since you could in theory use a
different key
by default when you open a new terminal
tmox is not going to be running
so we need to run it manually by running
the tmux command
after running it you'll after running it
you'll know you're inside of tmox
because you'll see a status bar
on the bottom of your terminal out of
the box the status bar is going to look
a bit different than what we see here
and we'll go over how to configure that
later on i made mine pretty minimal just
to maximize usable space while giving me
just enough information i care about
from here we have access to a bunch of
teammates goodies
for example if you hit prefix c you can
create a new window
notice on the bottom we have two windows
now instead of one
and both of them are named bash because
that's the shell i'm running
so let's say we've opened up a couple of
windows like we see here
and it starts to get confusing because
we're not sure what's running in each
window
if you hit prefix comma tmux will bring
up its command mode
and now we can rename the window by
typing in whatever you want as a new
name
and there we can see hello world you can
also switch to a different window by
hitting leader 2
or whatever number you want to switch to
the window you're currently looking at
will have a star next to it which makes
it easy to identify at a glance
by default tmux will order windows
starting at zero but in my tmx config i
change it to start at one
because in my opinion it's a lot easier
to hit backtick one rather than back to
zero also if you have mouse mode enabled
you can click any one of those windows
on the bottom to switch to it
and yeah i do have mouse mode enabled
just as an aside like i do use a mouse a
pretty decent amount of the time
especially for recording videos also as
another outside
uh i'm not trying to cover every single
tmux feature ever
there's other ways to switch between
windows 2 but i'm trying to focus
on what you might use in your day to day
now tmx has a help menu that you can
bring up with a prefix question mark
to learn about its binds and that's what
we see here the funny thing is
is i zoomed out to try to fit this all
in one screenshot but there's still
about half a dozen
lines above this and there's also the
man pages too
and plenty of cheat sheets available if
you google around but that said i
included a link to a cheat sheet in the
references
and yeah you're not meant to read this
by the way so going back to our example
before
if you want to split a window in half
you can use prefix b
to open a split below you but that's not
the default bind
instead i made it match the same
bindings as vim and there's really no
limit to how many times you can split a
window
you're basically limited to your monitor
screen resolution
in practice i do use split panes all the
time and you can switch between them
with the mouse
or if you use my tmx config you can also
use the up
or alt up or down arrows depending on
which direction you want to go
alternatively you can also split your
windows vertically this time around you
can do
prefix v which also matches my vim
keybinds
also while i'm not showing it here you
can combine horizontal and vertical
splits together
you can even drag the bar around with
your mouse to resize the panes
there's also resizing hotkeys for that
too but personally i don't use them
and i don't even know what they are off
the top of my head next up if you do
find yourself having a bunch of splits
open
but you want to temporarily zoom into
one of them without closing the rest of
your splits
you can do that with prefix z you can
tell if you zoomed in because it'll show
a z next to the window name
this is something i do all the time it's
especially handy if you're creating
video tutorials with a large font size
uh yeah and when you just want to zoom
into a specific split but i still do use
this in my day-to-day
with a regular font size too now there's
a lot more we can do with windows and
panes but
this goes back to the 80 20 rule which
is basically focusing on the 80
which is going to give you the most
benefit versus how much time you spend
in other words we just covered uh goes
in other words what we just covered goes
a really long ways for dealing with
windows
and split panes next up let's go over
another killer feature at tmx which are
sessions
if you hit prefix d that's going to
detach you from your current session
we didn't go over this yet but when we
run uh random tbx before
it started a session for us behind the
scenes and it named that session zero
since we didn't define a name that means
if we close our terminal
we could reattach to it and things will
be back as if we never left
if we ever forget what's running we can
use the tmux ls command to get a list of
sessions
in our case we have just the one here
then if we run the attach command
along with a specific session name we
can attach to that specific session
right now our session is named zero but
we can choose to rename it to something
else which we'll do in a few
also it's worth pointing out that if you
run tmux attached with no arguments
it'll attach you to the last used
session which is something i do all the
time
after running that attach command we're
back to our session from before
it's like we never left what's really
useful is you can have multiple sessions
running at once
and switch between them all that's a
game changer if you have a terminal
focused
development environment speaking of
multiple sessions if you're already in
tmux
uh already in a tbox session you can
create a new session by running
prefix colon to bring up command mode
and then you can run
the new session command i'm passing it
in a custom session name of cool here
but you can name it whatever you want
technically you can make a new session
without naming it
but i find in practice that naming your
sessions is worth it especially when
you're dealing with a few sessions
as for this animation right after this
session is created we can see that we're
put into a new session with only one
window
but our old session is still writing in
the background also if you're curious
most commands that you can run in
command mode
can also be run directly on the command
line although in this case if you try to
create a new session like
this when already in a session tmux is
going to prevent you from doing it by
default
otherwise it gets too crazy with nested
sessions however when you run new
session in command mode
that doesn't nest the new session within
an existing session
it creates a completely separate one i
know that's a little confusing
but that's just how it is as far as i
know the takeaway here is you should
always spawn new sessions from command
mode
if you're already inside a teamwork
session
as for switching between sessions you
can hit prefix s
this gives you a list of all of your
sessions and then you can use the arrow
keys to pick the one that you want
and switch to it and hit enter to select
it upon doing so you'll be put into that
session immediately
what's really cool is as you cycle
through the list of sessions you'll get
to see a preview of what's running in
the lower half of the window
that could be very handy to see what's
running in a session you can even click
directly into
one of those boxes there and jump
straight into that window next up let's
say that you want to search
up and down your buffer with the way i
have things configured you can use the
mouse wheel to scroll up in your buffer
and that puts you into tmux's copy mode
you can then i you can identify that by
the orange label in the top right
which shows the number of lines in the
buffer then you can hit the forward
slash to begin searching
type in whatever term that you want in
this case it's tmux and then hit enter
from there tmux will highlight all the
matches and you can jump to the next one
by pressing n
or go to the previous one with shift n
and this is what i meant by super
tmx supercharging your terminal suddenly
we can do this with any terminal and
that's awesome
now with the way i have things
configured if you select any text with
the mouse and let go of the mouse button
it'll copy that text to your clipboard
that's due to using a tmux plugin called
yank you can even use the mouse wheel or
the page up and down keys to quickly
select a bunch of text that is multiple
pages long
copy pasting is a pretty common thing to
do and i'm sure you'll be using that one
all the time
i know i do next up it's worth pointing
out that if you open two separate
terminals
you actually can connect to both of them
to the same session
when you do this your actions are going
to be mirrored in both terminals
that includes both typing and switching
windows by default tmux will also resize
the viewport of both terminals to be
whatever the smaller one is
to be honest i'm actually not too sure
why it does that but
you can change the behavior for example
if you attach to the session like this
along with setting one config option
then you can connect to the same session
but each terminal will have its own
independent view of a specific window
this is very very handy if you have
multiple monitors
it means you can have a second terminal
open on your other monitor
and look at a different window on the
same session that's running on your main
monitor
i do this quite often when i'm working
on projects that require seeing
many things at once lastly let's say
that you're detaching
or you're detached from tbox and you
want to stop all of your sessions
you can do that by running the tmux kill
server command
that's going to completely kill tmux
destroy all of your sessions
and stop any processes that we're
running in the foreground inside of tmox
this could be handy if you get lazy and
not name your sessions after a few weeks
of using tmux
without rebooting and you wind up with
having 20 unnamed sessions and 50 copies
of vim running
been there done that as for rebooting by
default you'll lose all of your sessions
after you reboot
on linux that's not really too bad
because you might not reboot for six
months but on windows
well that's a little bit painful because
windows will decide to reboot your
machine
whenever it feels like but there is a
silver lining there's a plugin called
tmux resurrect
that will let you save and restore your
sessions after a reboot or
killing the tmux server with that said
let's quickly go over
a few interesting parts of my tmox
config for the sake of time we're not
going to really spend as much time as
you did
going over the shell related configs
also my config is pretty well commented
so it should be fairly easy for you to
take a look at
and more detail on your own
like the other config files we'll show a
little bit at a time
and this is how you could customize your
prefix key
there's really not much to it if you
wanted to use something other than the
backtick
you would change it here next up this
one is
super interesting this is the setting
that allows you to get independent
windows when connecting to the same
session
multiple times apparently resizing isn't
enough you need to aggressively resize
to get your independence
these settings control the status bar i
explicitly removed everything except
showing the windows numbers
and labels by default tmx shows a clock
on the bottom right hand side of the
status bar
and i have that disabled here with
comments now if you google around for
tmok status bar configuration you'll
find a bunch of examples on what you can
do
for example you can add things like you
know your network ip address and battery
life and things like that
you know that could be handy if you're
connecting to multiple remote machines
especially for the ip address these
settings work together to make tmux a
bit more human friendly
for example if you had four windows and
you closed window two
then tmux by default will leave a
numbered gap what i mean by that is you
would end up with windows 1
3 and 4 being available the first
setting removes the gaps so you would
end up with windows 1
2 and 3. the other settings on the
bottom make tmuk start numbering windows
at 1
instead of 0. next up you can quickly
reload your tmux config by hitting
prefix
r that's handy to do if you're tweaking
your tmux config
and you want to see the changes without
having to kill your tmux server
this is very similar to sourcing your
bashrc file to see the changes without
having to open a new terminal
lastly tmx has plug-ins and the tool to
manage them is called tpm
that stands for tmux plug-in management
manage oh wow how did i mess that one up
that stands for tmux
plug-in management wow manager in case
you're wondering
it's something you'll need to install
and it's included in my dot files
documentation
uh the yank plugin copies selected text
to your clipboard
and the resurrect plugin lets you save
and restart tmx sessions even if your
tmux server dies
and you can do that by hitting prefix
control s to save your sessions and
prefix control r
to restore them once you're inside of
any tmux session
and that's really all you have to do
this plugin is awesome especially if
you're on windows
now let's talk a little bit about them
unlike the tmx section this is going to
be more
like a rapid fire description of a bunch
of vin plugins that i use in my day to
day
that's because to really get into vim
would require its own dedicated talk
instead of a couple of minutes
if you're curious i do have over 15
videos on youtube covering a bunch of
them topics
i've linked to them in the reference
notes lastly i do run regular vim
not neovim but all of these plugins will
work with vim 8.1 or above
and neovim speaking of plugins we'll
need a tool to install them
the vim has many different choices for
how to install plugins since it's been
around for so long
the one i use is called plug and you'll
see how to install it once we get to the
dot file section
and that's coming up next none of these
plugins are in any specific order
but let's start with the ones that we've
seen during this talk all the code
snippets you see here
are straight from my vim config file as
for fcf it allows us to fuzzy search
files
text git commits and more it's one of my
favorite plugins
fern allows you to quickly visualize
your project's directory structure
and it makes it really easy to rename
copy or delete files and directories
now it even supports bulk renaming files
in a vim buffer for doing complex
renaming
that could come in really handy if you
want to reorganize how you label media
files or whatever you might be doing
next up signify is a super efficient
plugin for displaying get changes like
we saw during the markdown preview demo
you know that's when we get a chance to
see the orange exclamation points
it also uses a green plus sign for new
lines and a red dash for deleted lines
then for preview markdown i use this
plugin it's labeled as being for neovim
because it ends there with uh
nvim but it still works with vim 8.1 or
above
this is the plugin that requires having
node installed also we saw
this plug-in display markdown that looks
like github styles but you can easily
change that by swapping out a css file
in case you decide that you want to use
get lab bitbucket
or you just want your markdown to look
different for csv files there's really
not much to say other than this plugin
works very nicely
by the way i have about 20 other plugins
related to syntax highlighting
for all the different languages and
tools i use on a regular basis
that's one of the reasons why i really
like vim it lets me use the same tool
for everything
multi snips and vim snippets really help
with providing shortcuts for inserting
code
most editors have some type of snippet
support and these work really nicely in
vim
as for this other plugin it tells vim to
automatically pop up its code complete
window while you
type i'm not sure if you've ever used
something like sublime text in the past
but it's very similar to that where you
can just start typing and
anything that's in any one of your open
buffers will just come up in that
autocomplete window
the cool thing about this is none of
these plugins require running a language
server
uh if you happen to know what that is uh
this is more for like a lightweight
approach to get useful
but not hyper intelligent autocomplete
that's context aware
moving on this one lets you zoom in and
out of splits and vim
just like you can do with this comes in
very handy if you're someone who likes
to open a bunch of splits
now all of these plugins work together
to serve the end goal
of making it easier for you to find
search and replace text
i use these all the time especially the
visual star and vim
grepper plugins there's a 30 minute
video linked in the references that goes
over how to do various find and replace
workflows in vim
it ranges from searching for a character
in online to doing a regular expression
based find and replace across multiple
files
lastly there's two themes that i really
enjoy using
both of them have really good syntax
highlighting for many popular languages
including r now i used one dark for all
the screenshots in this talk
and i typically use it when recording
videos and then i switch over to one
light for personal use
prior to that i used groov box for about
two years i still really like roof box
but like most developers we get boarded
themes over time
so i like to mix it up but i could see
myself switching back to it in the
future
besides tmax are besides plugins related
to syntax highlighting
there's still about 10 or 15 plugins
that i didn't mention which are still
worth using
for specific things now i don't quite
have 200 plugins but i would say i have
about 45 or 50
but i do use them on a regular basis i'm
very protective of which plugins i add
and i also focus on keeping things as
efficient as possible
you know that means not using plugins
that introduce typing delays or other
hitches
with that said all the plugins i use are
listed in my vmrc file in my dot files
which are also have one line commenting
explaining what each one does
and that's going to wrap things up for
vim now let's talk a little bit about
dot files we've already seen a couple of
them such as the profile
bash rc and tmux config files when it
comes to configuring user settings for
command line tools
it's very common to put them into
various dot files it's not a guaranteed
vote but most chameleon tools will use
files that begin with a dot for its
configuration
and there's three main places where they
might exist some tools will write their
config files into your user's home
directory
which is what we saw before with the
bashrc file tmux config and a couple
others
it's also quite popular for tools to
create a dot directory
in your home directory named after that
tool for example if you take a look here
at my home directory
here's a couple of tools that do that
this usually happens when a tool has
more than one config file but not always
sometimes a tool will place a bunch of
files unrelated to its configuration
along with its configuration all in one
spot it's also pretty popular for tools
to place their config files within their
own
directory within the dot config
directory inside of your home directory
that's a lot of directories uh this is a
newer standard based on something called
the xdg-based directory specification
which is linked in the reference notes
if you want to learn more about
conventions
or where certain files should live
highly recommend checking that out
and uh we can see that here if i happen
to write any scripts that need one or
more config files
i always use the dot config directory
since it's a standard
so that's how configuration is mainly
handled but i sort of simplified where i
store
my individual dot files just to make the
previous slides a bit easier to read
in reality most of my dat files are
sim-linked to a separate directory
that's contained within a git repo you
can see that here with the arrow pointer
which is a sim link
sim links are references to another file
or directory you can sort of think of
them as shortcuts if you're coming from
the windows world
they're not specific to dot files but
they're often used together with daf
files so you can save your data files
in one centralized location and then sim
link them to wherever they need to go in
your home directory
and that leads us into one way of
managing your data files
i'm a fan of having a single directory
somewhere on my system
such as this dot files repo in my github
folder and then i can sim link the
config files to where they need to go
this keeps things simple and it makes it
easy to replicate my setup on another
machine
or share it with others all you would
have to do is clone down this repo
set up the sim links and you're off to
the races
but sim links are not the only way to
manage your data files there's dozens of
tools focused on dot files management
but honestly i never felt the need to go
that far
a really popular one is called yet
another dot files manager
and i've dropped a link to it in the
references it's basically an abstraction
on top of get and it comes with its own
command line tool to manage your dat
files
if you do find yourself gravitating
towards wanting to use the dot files
manager
i would start with this one i haven't
used it personally but i do know someone
who is happily using it
that someone has been working on the
command line for 15 plus years
and he looked at a lot of different
tools so i trust his recommendation
with that said let's take a look at a
few key parts of my dot files repo on
github
in addition to the config files
themselves i included screenshots and
documentation related to installing the
tools i use
on a few popular linux distros and mac
os there's not really an unwritten rule
to include installation instructions in
your dot files
but i decided to go the extra mile i
included that mainly because i have a
few programming courses
and i wanted a single place where i
could point folks too in case i wanted
to replicate or cherry pick a couple of
things for my setup
for example if you wanted to install
tmux vim and a number of other tools
you could copy paste one of the package
installation commands depending on what
os you're using
in this case it's the debian and ubuntu
installation instructions but
in the readme file there's a copy
pasteable command for brew
in case you're using macos you can also
choose to add or remove anything you see
fit
for example jq is a command line tool
that lets you parse json
if you don't care about that then you
can just easily remove it
then for installing the dot files
themselves it's a matter of cloning this
repo
and then setting up the sim links you
can choose to grab all of my configs or
just the ones that you care about
for example if you find yourself using z
shell inside of bash
you could just remove my rc file or if
you're not using wsl
you can remove the last sim link there
since that only applies to wsl
also if you want more control over your
setup and you want a very personalized
solution
you can always skim through my
individual configs and copy paste
whatever you want
directly into your config files beyond
that there's a bunch of commands like
this where you can pick and choose to
install whatever tools you want
there is quite a bit more than what's
shown here but all the rest are
documented in the same way
and all of these commands are going to
work on linux and macos
since it's mainly running curl get and
pip commands pip is python's package
manager by the way
then there's even reminders like this in
the readme file too for installing
plugins for vim
and tmox there's also this section here
to help verify that everything is set up
correctly
lastly it's worth mentioning that these
dot files are going to evolve over time
in the references i've linked to the
exact commits for all the files we went
over
but i do recommend checking out the
master branch on your own because if
you're watching this talk in the future
chances are i've updated a number of
things which are probably improvements
in some way or another
so that's the tldr on that files
if you google around for dot files or if
you google around for dot files github
you'll find hundreds of other examples
i'm not really too sure how how many of
them will have
tons of documentation but at least now
you're familiar with the concept
and i think that's the main takeaway of
this talk you know i tried my best to
showcase and go over a bunch of tools
but ultimately it's up to you
to apply as as much or as little as you
want in your daily workflow
like anything it takes time to build up
muscle memory especially for hitting
hotkeys that might be foreign to you
i know it took me a really long time to
get used to them and i still feel like i
have a lot to learn
in other words don't get discouraged if
you struggle for a while it gets better
over time
and on that note hopefully at the very
least i a couple of unknown
unknowns were discovered today usually
when i watch a talk or read a book i'm
hoping to walk away with at least one
nugget of information
that i can apply back to my day to day
and that's all i have
thanks a lot for having me and if anyone
is still awake and alive and we still
have time i'm more than happy to answer
any questions thanks
all right thank you very much that was a
whirlwind tour
uh yeah sitting here saying okay is he i
had a question like oh he answered that
question i had a question he answered
that question
and someone else sent me the similar
message that they want and they have
questions like oh you answered it
so right that was really excellent so
let me pull up the few questions we have
that may not still have been answered uh
to you you
went over so much stuff uh someone
mentioned it wasn't so much a question
but i'm mentioning about when you're
talking about manually setting colors in
your ps1
about t put have you ever looked at
using t put for setting colors
teapot not familiar is that the one
where you can it kind of just sets up
like variables for you to reference like
the color red instead of having to know
to use like 32
i am not sure uh hopefully someone in
the chat jks i think you're the one
asked it so
if you know then what tipa does let us
know in the chat
right right is he saying that he doesn't
like all those escape codes come on
yeah no those are fun to use when i
first started learning those i'm like uh
how am i supposed to get these right oh
i missed the care i missed the bracket
i'm screwed
right i did a lot of backing up when i
tried using it as the first time
uh you mentioned asdf briefly could you
just
quickly uh mention that uh go over that
again yeah so
well i don't know who asked the question
and like what programming languages that
they use but asdf
is kind of like a general or purpose
multi tool that allows you to set up
different versions of let's say python
or node
or elixir or ruby or any programming
language and you can kind of just like
independently isolate all of your
different versions it's kind of like i
guess using a
virtual env in python it could be
comparable to that but it's more
primarily used in uh like the node in
ruby and elixir community
honestly i don't use it that much
because i i pretty much dockerize all of
my apps but
yeah it's kind of useful for when i have
to install node can that work for any
generic programming language or is it
just for a certain subject
yeah i mean i there's support for the
tool internally
i don't know the exact list off the top
of my head but if you check their page
out on github it has a full list of
all the languages supported alright cool
that could be that's a whole big thing
you know
you have conda and v v n for python you
have r e and v
for r but r and v for r just handles the
packages it doesn't handle the version
so that's actually the burden of
ourselves that's really nice to know
yeah cool um someone asking now this
might
start a fight um how practical is emacs
as the basis for the ecosystem you
described
honestly it's it's really opinion i mean
you can go
if you want to use emacs it's like
basically a different thought process in
my opinion
so going like the vim and tmox and my
command line approach it's like you're
just
putting together all of these tiny tiny
little laser-focused tools
but what is that joke around emacs being
like it's a pretty decent editor
but it's a really good os right it's
like
emex becomes your world uh which in a
you know in a way is
definitely an advantage uh there's some
good stuff about that right just being
able to write one scripting language and
do all of your stuff there but
it's just not for me but uh don't let me
deter you there
as i said for me and i'm sure a lot of
people here our studio is their world
like i can never leave our studio like
i could do everything i ever need to do
in our studio and never have to go
anywhere else
in fact it even has a vim and emax mode
has both modes
uh someone is asking let me put on my
screen i can see it better
um are you still working on a full stack
course that you mentioned a year ago
man putting me on the spot on that one
yeah
yeah i am but it's uh it's pretty
involved and
there was like over 190 video tutorials
and i got all the way through that and i
decided to like axe the whole project
just because i felt like it got too
boring in the middle and i just gutted
it and basically i'm working on it now
okay so we expect to see that what next
week or something uh
yesterday maybe sure yes i will promise
it for yesterday
yeah um someone asked me about have you
have they answered well asked me to ask
you if you've heard of nvim-r
nvim-r i have not unfortunately
i have very limited experience with r in
the sense that like i've never even uh
looked at the language at all let me
just make sure that was the right thing
they asked about
i think it's it's it's a yeah and oh
it's nvim-r-t-mux
it's an integrated working environment
for r i think it just sort of i'm
guessing it probably puts an r console
into vim so you can make a ripple out of
it as my guess
yeah so there's a whole bunch of plugins
i didn't really talk about that are very
specific to different programming
languages like
you can have automated tests where you
can just like move your cursor into
a specific test that you have and hit a
hotkey and then it just runs that test
so yeah there's all sorts of stuff like
that um have you put
any have you done any videos or putting
any work i have any thoughts about using
vs code
as sort of a command station
sort of kind of but i feel like and you
do mean like using like vim mode instead
of inside of vs code
i say that by using a vs code for its
terminal and using that as your editor
instead of them whether you use the vim
bindings or not
and sort of making that your entry point
into linux as opposed to the terminal as
your entry point
yeah that's definitely not a bad idea
the reason i don't use that i guess is
because like i really am juggling a lot
of different projects like we're talking
like you know eight to like ten
different projects all the time
and uh i mean i guess opening like 10
copies of vs code if i had like one
instance for each of them on like you
know a virtual desktop or something and
i switched to that that could work but
i'd also need like
half a terabyte of ram to uh run that
many concurrent copies of vs code
whereas vim even with those 50 plugins
it's like eight megs of ram
for uh for each copy that's pretty good
um vs code i've been using a lot lately
because it
has the language server and the ssh
compatibility sdh into my server and it
feels local
which i guess for you you've got your
vim set up to feel local
yeah so the like the one thing i really
miss from vs code like i work with a lot
of containerized applications like their
remote containers feature is awesome
and as far as i know there's nothing
like that in vim so you know
it still does call to me once in a while
i don't use it but
it's there in like the back of my head
all right very cool
um there's a question just came in
when you're at and i'm doing these sort
of out of order the way they came in
just those things pop
to me when you're at the shell and you
find a file to open
how do you open it in vim without
clobbering your shell window that you're
active in
how do i open it in vim without
clobbering the shell so do you mean like
let's see i have uh i do have a terminal
ready here i wasn't lying about being
ready for
the live demos there but do you mean
like if i wanted to open up
this directory here in vim like how do i
make this not clobber
this current window so i would just open
up another tmx window like this
and it would just jump to the to the
other windows that i want to jump to
so i wouldn't worry about like not
collaborating it i would just open a new
uh window
did i answer your question anthony um
they just he opens a new window in tmux
and technically you can also do
something like uh what is a control z or
something to send it to the background
and then you can use uh
to run to get back to it that also works
but i mean at that point i feel like
it's just easier to open a tmx window
okay i guess so yeah same thing as
follow-up like so you would clobber it
but
in a new window instead of the other one
i guess there's a way to make it
like modals they're totally the wrong
word you know if you open a program in
windows it could be like a
like a smaller program in front of the
program behind it can you do something
like that
uh maybe it's not something i don't have
any experience with i haven't set
anything like that i feel like that
would be probably
something with your operating system
like maybe like layering a different
terminal on top of your existing
terminal something like that
i don't know then speaking of multiple
terminals i know you can open up
multiple terminals and windows i'm sure
other operating systems and even the
windows terminal has multiple tabs
how do you feel about the using those
tabs and even
terminals has now windows terminal has
built-in splitting
so where does that fit in with tmux and
everything
and very very rarely would i use those
features because like if i just want to
split that i just do it with tmux and
there you go but you know jumping over
here i am using windows terminal here so
like i can just open up a new tab there
now it's a little small because uh the
font size but you know i will use this
feature of the tabs like once in a blue
moon but honestly just usually
you know the same exact thing could be
uh done with a tmux window like i
i feel like the windows here are
basically tabs but they're not
and i guess for someone who gets a lot
of people coming as new
if they want to use let's say they have
one terminal tab
but they want to split the panes like
how do they can you marry both t-mucks
and the windows terminals
planes pain splitting or you sort of
devote yourself one to the other uh you
can probably combine them both
but at that point i would ask myself
like why do you need to combine them
both like i would pick one or the other
okay that's fair um
here's one and you're when you're doing
your tmunk tmux config you had set
you had set w you had set dash g uh what
were the differences between those
well let me see if i can open that up
tmux.com
so there is a whole bunch of different
ones yeah i know i know what he means
like set ga
and like set option and set w like what
the heck is all that
uh good question i think these are like
compatibility things don't quote me on
that one i hate to give bad information
over a talk but
i mean it's a lot of just like googling
for how do i like raise the history
limit in tmux
finding a stack overflow answer with
like a million up votes and not too many
people saying it's it's garbage and then
i just use it and it works
so i keep it okay that's definitely
like renumber windows it's set option
and base index is set that
you'd have to search but which would be
nice if there's a logical reason which
i'm sure there is somewhere
in the back of some you know linux devs
mine from 30 years ago
right like this is a great example like
this base index like why do i have to
set it twice like maybe in theory with
this one
one of these will work but it's one of
those things where like my config is
still valid and tmux is not yelling at
me so i haven't really gotten rid of it
and especially since the second one is
set w so it's even it's not just setting
it twice segments that w
yeah and it's a totally different
variable name to base index versus pain
based index well maybe these are
separate to be honest i'm not 100
but they're both set here for a reason
so i'm hoping that uh
it was valid yeah yeah well it's working
i guess right
yeah um here's another one
how do you integrate this when running a
script like an r script or a python
script or
insert generic script there and you did
as soon as they answer that question
they asked that question you did
answer it in your talk but i just want
to throw it in there
that's when you're talking about the
shebangs so how do you
how do you integrate scripts into your
workflow do you mean like developing
them like if i were to be developing a
script
usually like my font size is so blown
out here but typically i'd have uh you
know like
the script here in vim like i'm hacking
away on the script on the left and then
i'm just like
running it on the right like up arrow
enter up arrow enter so it's like i have
a side-by-side view of being able to
develop the script and then run it at
will
okay let's assume that's what they're
asking so i'm not exactly sure um
i do that all the time like if i'm
developing any type of script
okay um how do you keep
so how do you keep so many
there's we're missing how do you keep
key mapping straight i guess how to keep
so many key mappings straight
between auto hockey vim teammates etc
etc yeah
it's so many that it's insane but
honestly uh sticky notes goes a really
long way so like when i was learning
these hotkeys which i still fumble from
time to time
just sticking like eight different
sticky notes on my monitor just help me
just
fuse them into my brain and eventually
just becomes muscle memory
and uh you just yeah just get to it
now as for not clobbering the different
keys like you know stepping on each
other's toes
then that's where the things like the
prefix key and leaders key comes into
place with tmux and vim
so if i'm running like a tmux command
here like if i do
leader b to to split this there it's not
really competing with anything else in
my system because nothing else really
has that bind where i'm doing the back
tick
and then you know something else
and for auto hockey uh we didn't go over
that that's not really command line
focused i guess but usually i just bind
those to like windows keys like
you know windows e or something like
that windows z is taken
that's the explorer but yeah bad example
but yeah
windows w will open up a web browser for
me which i don't want to do now but
yeah i have a couple of those set up
this question i think i know we're going
to go how do you get the unix commands
on windows
so that i mean there's multiple ways but
the way i prefer to do it is the windows
subsystem for linux
and uh that is what we're looking at
here like i'm actually running uh let me
just maybe
kill these out here just so we can see a
little bit better i am running ubuntu
2004 here so this is just wsl2
so this is something that microsoft
released and uh you can basically just
run it like i am running windows here
you can't see my full screen
but there is like a windows 10 taskbar
below here and yeah it just runs like
it's a tool you can install
it's actually if you go to my dot files
repo there's a link there that goes over
how i have my entire windows development
environment set up it's like a 30 minute
video
so i'm actually going to ask a follow-up
on that one um
where does git bash now fall into play
now that wsl 2 has become mature
wsl and generals become mature do you
still have to have git bash to get git
on the windows side or do
you would you use git from wsl on your
windows files
yeah so i don't use git bash at all like
everything right now is developed
primarily inside inside of wsl too so i
have get installed here
okay now and and i do know that the git
installed here
works on windows files and i understand
between wsl1 and wsl2 there is a speed
difference in accessing
files on the other file system so would
w using git on wsl 2
uh be fast enough to you to use git on
windows files if that made sense
probably like if you have your drive
mounted to where you have windows files
then it's probably not going to be fast
enough because i found that you're right
like that mount speed is just
horrendously slow i mean i would imagine
in future releases
it's going to get better but in this
case like in my home directory source
here
all of my source code is living inside
of wsl2 so it is lightning fast
so you can do that and you can still
access these files from windows as well
so if you want to open them up in
you know rstudio or whatever you can
still do that that's going to be the
next question of all of your code files
lives in wsl and you just answered that
yeah also if you use vs code then it has
really good support for wsl as well
okay um this is not a question but a
comment
um definitely have to watch this a few
more times to get everything
and this takes me back to the days and
the command line is how we did
everything
yeah i guess there's some uh nostalgia
factor for someone who might be
using the terminal for a long time and
maybe just took a break and
did whatever this reminds me back when i
used das back in the day and like that
gauze is much better than das but
i couldn't remember anything and
nowadays oh yeah i'm back at the command
line right where i was i don't know how
many years ago
right um i'll give a last chance if
there's any other questions we went
through a lot of them
i'm sure nick is exhausted yeah
i almost passed out at like the 38
minute mark
glad you're still with us yep yeah it's
really hot here in long island and i
can't put my ac
on because it's just too loud for the
mic oh
it's awful yep oh then one question that
was then so why
since you're gonna start sweating
bullets um your favorite backup tool
favorite backup tool good question uh
that i
actually wrote a shell script called
backup and it just uses
rsync and then it just copies certain
directories that i've whitelisted over
to an external drive
that's like an external usb drive so
yeah i kind of sort of don't want to
show that one on video because there's
certain directories in there that
i don't know off the top of my head if i
want to show them fair fair but
if your tool is available somewhere they
can find it yeah so
if you go to if you just google for like
nick gen attack is
rsync backup you'll find a blog post
with the whole entire script and
an explanation of all of it great
all right so i think that was a
lot of questions we had everything
answered let me just give a quick scroll
to make sure i didn't miss anything i
feel like looking back and replaying the
talk of my head i think i may have
misspoke a little bit about asdf like it
wouldn't replace virtual ends with
python
but it could replace installing a
specific version of python but you'd
still want to use a vm
inside of that got it because the vm is
because the vm does a lot more than just
the one version of the
language it's sort of embarrassing
because like i've been working with
docker for so long like every time i
docker write like if i'm developing a
flask up or a python app it's just
i'm just using docker very rarely do i
use asdf
fare yeah docker's become such a thing
now now it's big in the art community
for uh doing uh reproducible research um
and so actually let me ask you one more
question you just trigger one in my mind
so many so i know i think traditional
devs use docker
as they build on their computer they use
docker to capture the state of their
computer
or i think a lot of data scientists will
want to develop
inside the docker containers they want
to get the environment set up first just
that way then develop in it
what pattern do you typically follow uh
i usually go for the pattern of just
running one process inside of each
container
so for example uh in this flask example
here i mean i
you know there's no harm in showing this
here so if i open up like
my docker compose file here i am running
postgres
and redis and uh the flask like unicorn
web server itself as well as celery like
a background worker but these are all
running in
individual docker uh just containers so
like postgres is its own image redis you
know these are the official ones but
yeah even like the unicorn web server
and
salary this works off the same code base
but i do have them running in separate
containers
and so you do docker compose up and then
do your coding
in one of these containers is your
coding done in your machine
yes no i'm coding on my machine and then
they're uh they're volume mounted in
so i mean it's a little bit cryptic to
read with these environment variables
but
yeah it's just a volume out so these are
just sitting on my local box
if i have one of these windows open yeah
very cool
all right um all right sorry one more
question someone snuck this in
um don't you worry about one of your 50
vin pluggings having a security
vulnerability
and and stealing your ssh keys et cetera
or something like that
uh that's actually a really good
question because like for a lot of
things especially if you're working with
um
you know python or node or something
like that
a package could be open source but the
code that you see on github technically
isn't the code that is running on your
machine because the code that's running
on your machine is whatever they decided
to publish to uh
you know pi pi or you know npm or
whatever uh but for vim
uh the way plug works the plug-in
manager it's just get cloning stuff
on your drive so if i go to i think it's
in my vin
directory in my home directory i think
under plugged
like there's just a million plugins in
here some of them have
weird file permissions from wsl1 so
ignore like the hard to read ones but
uh all of these are just on github
somewhere so you are free to check out
all the code that you want
whether or not you want to go in there
and look at like 800 000 lines of vim
script that's up to you
but uh i kind of just trust the system
sort of
just like if you're installing any
dependencies like heck i'm running
windows here so
yeah so you're trusting the community to
have seen the code and someone has
calling bs that there's something bad
yeah i mean i mean
there's not really that much else you
can do other than you personally
auditing like every single line of code
we're not all richer stallman yeah um
and since you showed us your ls there
what does the dark green background
means i think you know a lot of us get
that with different colored backgrounds
and our ls listings and
sometimes wonder what it means at least
i do oh let me go back to that one
yeah so right now the file permission of
like the ones that are almost impossible
to read
i i'm guessing they're just set to like
seven seven seven so like they're
executable
and the problem with the wsl1 because i
migrated from wsl one to two is it just
didn't support linux file permissions at
all so it just made everything 777 so
now i have all these directories and
files on my system that are messed up
like this but
i could change these to be what they
should be so like if i just do i don't
know like a chmod
zero seven seven five on like the vim
zoom one like notice here on the bottom
them zoom is the green color but now if
i do this uh it should be back to normal
so i should go back in here and do this
to all them but whatever like it's not
that big of a deal
in this case so but i guess the answer
then is like typically the
green background means that it's 777
permissions yeah so if you look here on
the left hand side
maybe you can't read the text or
whatever but you can see the the
permissions are different than the other
ones
awesome all right cool all right
so thank you so much thank you anthony
for the moderator
comment uh thank you very much nick for
doing for uh speaking
everyone the video will be up in
a few a day or two depending on what i
can edit it the slides you made
available if you have
any slideshows you can send that to us
we'll put it up on the ny hack our site
um remember you can get in touch with
nick there you go a bunch of ways to get
in touch with him directly
um follow him on twitter i know that's a
comment that this community loves
twitter
uh next three months we have katarina we
have henrik we have
will we have the dc conference coming up
in december the information is coming
out
the videos from the our conference
coming out uh that'll be happening
soon and yeah everyone check out ny hack
r for more stuff
and i look forward to seeing you next
month in the ensuing month so thank
everyone for coming
you know i had a great time i learned a
lot i hope everyone else did too uh
thank you nick
yeah thanks a lot for having me
and i'll just uh sit here while we let
people uh drift away and see if there's
any last stragglers
right maybe one day we could figure out
about how to open this up so people
could hang out like we did last week so
last week we had a hangout
people just got together and hung out
and ate pizza drink beer drink soda
whatever they drink
or food that isn't pizza i don't know
why anyone eat anything that's not pizza
but they were and we just hung out it's
sort of nice because after these meetups
we usually go out afterwards to the
local bar and hang out we can't do that
anymore unfortunately so
maybe next time we'll find a way to
convert this into a hangout session
after the meetup
that's more for armada than you next
sorry
yeah okay at this point i think
everyone's sort of leaving now but oh
there's still 23 i don't know how to
switch it over so i don't even want to
guess
because i don't know what i'm doing so
here's a real question while people
trickle away
how do you drink on a zoom without
looking like an idiot
oh it's hard it is hard yeah so you so i
teach
um like i teach three hour classes for
columbia every monday right so it's
three hours
now on an unzoom in a row like straight
from like two to five
i got myself like a big adult sippy cups
like a big cup this big of a big thick
straw and i just sit there
like a child drinking out of the sippy
cup uh because i can't find anything
better like
right now my sippy cups being cleaned i
have a glass which is dangerous
it's brittle it's like they were in that
guy's career we know it's rubio like it
sort of hurt his career a little bit
when he had to reach for the cup and
drink while on camera
um of course he had to reach for like
three feet out of his way it was kind of
silly
i don't have a good answer for you it's
hard yeah i feel bad because i hit my
mic once i don't know at one point but
it was months
no and at least i didn't notice let's
put it that way
yeah someone's saying oh it's very nice
nick you didn't look stupid actually it
was a total non-issue
thanks jks is asking for the link to the
github repo for the dot
files which i assume is up on
your github somewhere yeah it's like
somewhere so it's funny because the way
i'm showing my screen and zoom right now
i can't even see my url bar
so i don't even know where i am in the
slide deck but it is light yeah here we
go perfect so this is live right now you
can go check it out
there you go ny github.com nick jj
slash nyhakar dash cli dash dev dash env
yup cool oh yes that's in the
uh slack oh we also have a sock
everybody
and i'll repost it here yeah in a couple
of days too when you upload that video
then i'll update uh
the link there too in the readme file to
link to that video
great we have a collection of videos
going back i think
our videos go back about six or seven
years and we have slideshows going back
11 years now wow yeah this is a
there's a lot of resources in this
community
so how bad did i butcher that guy's name
by the way the one who gave that command
line talk
your rune johnsons so hard to pronounce
it i practiced it too like 10 times
before the talk i i've no i've known him
for maybe
eight ten years and it took me a few
years until even to his face i could get
his name right
um i said as an american doesn't speak
any other languages duchess
was i just had to get used to it yeah
yeah he gave a um a really good talk he
wrote a whole book about data science in
the command line i think he's working on
the second edition right now
um it was a really popular talk it was
really good
yeah people yearn for the command line
all right so with that i think everyone
sort of most people trickled away as a
few people lingering
watching us talk so i'll just say uh
have a good night everyone enjoy the
debate if you're watching that tonight
um otherwise we'll see you next month
for katarina and ensuing months
and just feel free to reach out on slack
on twitter any way you want to be in
touch
always looking to say hi that's dance
from elise and i assume nick loves being
contacted too
yeah sure everybody here is very
friendly so um thank you very much
everyone and i'll see you soon
i'll kill the meeting right thank you
thank you nick thank you nick